when you defeat the bosses of boletaria
take a closer look at the dissipation
effect that they leave behind
traced really briefly in their soul
remains is an imprint of their human
form
the tower knight the penetrator and true
king allant
all have this fairly straightforward
imprint but
what helps to mark these as truly
special
are the soul remains of phalanx take a
look here we see a bowman
or perhaps more specifically a bow woman
since phalanx is a demonic reflection of
a character called
longbow ullan who is one of the
legendary boletarian heroes
king alant led boletaria with a round
table of the bravest knights
the noble twin fangs falafax and bjor
alfred the tower knight metas the
penetrator
and the brave tribesmen longbow ullan
and his fearsome legions
so despite being a more monstrous demon
than the others phalanx too leaves
behind a human imprint
as she is one of four boletarian heroes
that
inspired the old ones demons and as far
as i've tested
it's only these four bosses that leave
behind a human
imprint but it is also interesting to
note that some boss soul icons
do have shapes that correlate to their
character like the lightning bolt of the
storm king
the winged dragon god and false king the
searing demon soul and you can even see
spider legs in the hard demon soul
for more secrets like this listen on and
thank you to expressvpn for sponsoring
this video
so while it's easy to assume that these
heroes were transformed into demons
bio suggests that these boss fights are
more accurately
reflections of these heroes that the old
one is creating
instead in his japanese dialogue he
calls penetrator a
brazen sham of a knight and we can trust
beeo's opinion on this because
he too was a hero of boletaria alongside
metas the knight that is reflected by
the penetrator if we're looking for the
actual souls of these heroes
perhaps we should refer instead to their
black phantom forms
who bjor calls the black souls of great
knights
now you might have noticed earlier that
ostrava called longbow ulan
ahi but this has long been held to be a
translation error
since the original japanese doesn't ever
specify their gender
what does clue us in to phalanx or
ulaan's gender though
is one of the three black phantoms that
you fight in 1-4
one is the black phantom form of alfred
the knight of the tower
carrying the tower knight shield the
next is metas the knight of the lance
carrying the penetrator's sword and the
third female phantom
is logically the tribesman longbow ulan
who carries a white bow and a killage
which are weapons that
actually have connections to other
tribesmen of the shrine of storms
so all of these characters are
interwoven from their boss forms to
ostrava's dialogue to their red phantom
forms as well
so similar to old king alant who is a
demonic reflection of the true king of
art writhing beneath the nexus
the demon phalanx tower knight and
penetrator
are all demons that the old one modeled
off of boletaria's existing knights
who are more true to their form in the
black phantoms of 1-4
in fact it's actually these exact black
phantom models that make up the imprints
that are now left behind
in their boss soul remains i can tell
this because penetrator's imprint
doesn't have a helmet and the tower
knight's imprint is wielding a scraping
spear
and phalanx's imprint is obviously ulan
the bow wielding red phantom but if
you're still not convinced that phalanx
is this female red phantom
listen to the pain and death sounds of
phalanx
added into the remake
bluepoint has gone so above and beyond
with their sound design
i like it because they're really
expanding that from software creed of
adding details to their game that so few
will notice but
that add wonderful value and depth all
the same another great
sound example though can be found when
you approach a few select gates in the
tutorial
through which you can hear the tormented
screams of humans
and the gluttonous growls of the demon
vanguard
on a less immersive note if you look
carefully through the credits screen
you can actually see a bunch of goofy
looking goat faces
some of them very well hidden and blue
point has a bit of a history
with this in their shadow of the
colossus remake four goat paintings were
found
around the enormous world and again they
were very well hidden
to the point where players still aren't
quite sure if there's a fifth goat
lurking somewhere nothing has come with
these discoveries to this day
so in my opinion it's pretty likely that
this is just an internal joke for the
company
or maybe we're the internal joke and
they're just laughing at how desperate
we are to find everything
hmm the thing is you never really know
with bluepoint
because sometimes they deliver real
results in one of my recent videos we
talked about the 11 ceramic coins that
you need to find
if you want to unlock the secret door to
the penetrator's armor
but we speculated that there might still
be two more coins to discover
still hidden within the fractured world
well a few hours after that video
released those two coins were found
one is in pure black world tendency
halfway through
the third stage of boletaria castle
requiring you to jump over this ledge
onto the platform below
i can see why no one found this until
now putting it over a ledge jump that
wasn't in the original game is just
so genius the other coin is in the
second stage of the valley of defilement
which is one of those areas that must
have had like 100 players going through
it
at one point and we found nothing then
but after seeing the coin
i understand why in pure white world
tendency you need to fall
through this tiny little gap on this
non-descript piece of scaffolding
to land on a platform that contains the
coin
god damn this brings our total to 13
coins per new game cycle
and since you need to trade 26 with
snuggly to get the rusted key
that unlocks the door in 1-3 that means
you can actually get the penetrator's
armor set
in new game plus now which is a huge
improvement
over going to new game plus plus one of
the funnier quirks with these coins was
that they break
if you try to trade them to other
players which is something that
prevented players from
duping the coins by rolling back their
saves but
what it seems bluepoint didn't realize
is that players can drop the coins
for their hosts crow instead so
in this way if someone drops their coins
here for you as a host
you can reload your game as if you
dropped an item for sparkly and
you will receive the other players coins
back from sparkly instead
maybe they'll patch this soon so if you
want the penetrator armor in new game
this might be your only opportunity
before we knew that ceramic coins were
needed to open the secret door
players also speculated that it might
have had something to do with
the odd sharp echoes that you can
sometimes hear
when you're playing through the game
even now it is kind of hard to know if
these are a glitch
or something more user yojimbo the
despised has
this great post on reddit breaking down
how and where a lot of these sounds
appear
and they even managed to get some great
audio of it happening in the nexus have
a listen
i recommend you read their full post
because what if
there is something more to these wait
[Music]
i mean that kind of sounds like
one glitch that i hope they don't patch
is the ability to
continue wearing body type locked armor
after customizing your character at the
statue of reflection
what's also weird is that they did
remove the body type restrictions on
some armors you can wear the binded set
from miralda on any character now for
example
shortly after release notorious souls
expert illusory wall tweeted
i wonder how long it'll take for the
community to discover a
new glitch in the demon souls remake
that was actually just
undiscovered and in the original this
whole time
it turns out not long when i told him
about a tweet that i received claiming
that enemies in the remake were
less alert to sounds based on the weapon
that they were holding
he tested it in the original and it was
there as well
if you are two handing a large weapon
over your shoulder like the dragon bone
smasher
then enemies that are supposed to be
able to hear you have their sound
impeded for some reason by contrast this
character holding a smaller dagger
is detected far earlier we discover so
many things as a community
and one thing that my chat pointed out
while i was fighting the storm king on
twitch
was the amazing way that the rain
particles work in this fight
so when the enormous storm king passes
over you
the rain particles are actually
completely blocked and it stops
raining on your character isn't that
crazy similarly when you shoot a blast
from the storm ruler
it shears this path through the rain and
blasts the particles away with force
this game man the first stage of latria
here has
a very different tone to the original
thanks to the noble woman's singing and
while i personally prefer the haunting
tone in the original
which i consider canon
i can't help but think about the
implications of the song
that she's singing in the remake it's a
song from the demon soul soundtrack
returned to slumber it makes the
atmosphere here melancholy
even calming return to slumber is
basically a lullaby
after all it's the song that plays after
you choose the good ending
at the end of the game after the maiden
in black lulls the old one back to sleep
an interesting thing about her singing
it is that it does make some
sense for the once royal mistress to be
singing such a song
her and her fellow nobles were
imprisoned in latria
after all and she complains that the
demons feed upon their souls
so of course they'd want to end it by
putting the old one back to slumber
but even if it's not a reference to the
old one and it's probably not
it does still make some sense for her to
be filling the dungeon with a calm
atmosphere when you talk to her she
speaks of how her fellow prisoners are
lured above
by talk of redemption but it's a lie by
the demons to lure them out of course
but by singing a comforting song not a
haunting one
she is perhaps encouraging her fellow
prisoners
to stay below to stay sane it's a song
of
solidarity with them so again while i
feel like something is lost from the
original atmosphere
that doesn't mean something else can't
be gained i actually find this applies
to a lot of changes in the remake if you
think about them
critically and even if you dislike
something changes do spread awareness
about what made the original demon souls
so great one thing that
definitely wasn't in the original was a
dragon ball z
reference choose this phrase to be
offered a number list
and hidden at the bottom is this
very cool reference deserves a chuckle
at least right
and now you can even laugh in game you
laugh when you put on the fat official's
cap
and you grin evilly in the character
screen i love this additional flavor
it's great
but i will say i miss the old fat
official laugh there was just something
so
unsettling and inhuman about it
while i don't agree with every change
bluepoint just bought themselves so much
goodwill by responding to fan feedback
and changing some things before release
like the flame lurker's design another
example though is
when we all saw a preview of the fluted
set
we all reacted pretty negatively since
the helmet in the previews looked
way less fluted than it did in the
original but the original helmet is in
the game
i don't know if they added it in as a
response to this feedback but
you can get it it's just pretty hidden
so when you start up the game
opt into the journey to the nexus and
defeat the vanguard
the trick is to bait his short range
attacks and then get behind him
indefinitely
if you die here you can never return but
if you defeat him the game takes you to
the unknown egress
in this area you can pick up the fluted
helm which is a really special reward
one of the main reasons that the
vanguard design has grown on me is the
attention to detail with its design
so you probably know there are two demon
vanguards in the game
one in the tutorial and one in the
shrine of storms
and you might not have noticed this but
there's actually a design discrepancy
between the two of them the one that
inhabits the castle
is shackled it has cuffs on its limbs
and it has
chains that are designed very
specifically for its upper torso
this proof of past imprisonment or
restraint is a part of its story here
because it links it to the environment
and sort of tells a story that you can
imagine about the soldiers in this place
maybe they once restrained it but now it
seems like they guard and
possibly even feed it alternatively the
one in the shrine is
entirely free of shackles perhaps
suggesting that
it encountered less resistance when it
was at the front
of a demon army going through this place
we should all be free of shackles like
this and
that's kind of what it feels like to use
a vpn so having expressvpn
is also kind of like being in the nexus
because with the click of a button you
have the freedom to travel wherever you
want
to open up a world of new content for
your existing streaming services
take netflix for example if you're in
the us you can't watch
any of miyazaki's movies so with one
click
let's travel to world one australia
where the entire
suite of ghibli films is now available
for viewing
but in australia where i live i can't
watch the berserk
trilogy which is the series that
inspired a lot of dark souls if you
didn't know
so let's go to world 2 japan where i can
now access this huge range of anime that
isn't available in the west
but western fantasy inspired these games
as well
so what about lord of the rings it's not
available in the us
or australia right now but if i set a
canadian ip
through expressvpn it safely routes my
connection
through a different country my ip and my
location
are hidden from third parties and i get
access to their content so i can easily
view
the full lord of the rings trilogy in
just a few clicks and this is all with
my existing netflix subscription so you
don't deserve to be limited by the
country you're in
that's why i like using vpns and
expressvpn is one of the best
so sign up today with the link below
that's expressvpn.com and
you can find out how to get three months
free but thank you guys always for
watching and listening as well
maybe tell me what other shows i should
watch in the comments with my
three months free i'll talk to you next
time okay i've got a bonus secret for
you guys i was about to set this video
to render and it was literally just
discovered so i do want to talk about it
there's a ring called the providential
ring in this game
you can choose it as a starting gift or
you get it if you
buy the digital deluxe edition but apart
from that until now no one knew how to
get this ring and you needed this ring
to get the platinum trophy so a lot of
people were in a situation where they
couldn't get the platinum trophy
because they didn't choose this ring as
a starting gift but someone just figured
out where it is in the game
you have to go to sparkly the crow and
trade a large
sword of searching with her in order to
receive it from her and you get the
large sword of searching
from upgrading a plus 8 curved sword
with the hero demon soul
which you get from the old hero boss in
the shrine of storms
so that's it don't feel pressured to
choose this ring in the starting menu
anymore
and yeah i'll see you guys next time